Oh a sponsor is skin condoms skin ski
everywhere you ever wear condom you know
I know I'm [ __ ] but I don't feel
anything I know I'm [ __ ] but I don't
feel anything
make it feel like that's not leaving on
there it's made with some next-level
technology stuff that feel like you
rolling up in there oh closest to it you
still feel like it's something there but
it's just only a little bit it's the
least that it needs to be to still feel
good skin condoms skin skin skin they
feel good they're super soft and
comfortable skin condoms feeling like
you've rubbed all getting them use code
Rambler from today's show to receive
free shipping on all skin products at
buy condoms dot online that's rambler at
buy condoms that online skin condoms
just buy a bunch of them just by a
hundred get ahead of it you don't want
to be in that situation order uh Pat
your pockets looking around just get a
bunch of them and hope for the best to
live your best life
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome welcome back
club welcome for the first time I don't
know stay handsome rambling podcast my
Hannibal Birds
it's Tony trim hey episode 4 we're in
Chicago man it is a election night
Tuesday November 8 and when Chicago at
this point in time Trump is up in the
electoral votes uh who knows man is
Trump gonna be our president it's gonna
be determined by the time as heirs but
you get to catch us in anticipation in
state of not-knowing did you vote today
yeah yeah a state of complete anxiety
yeah I voted today I feel like I
shouldn't I'm sort of living back in
Chicago now it was some things that I
feel like I shouldn't be allowed to vote
for what I just skipped it was one of
the things of Chicago you can vote for
is the Water Reclamation Commissioner
did you vote on that no I didn't you
just skipped it yeah cuz I don't know
who no I mean it seems like water you
can't you can't really be that bias ding
not gonna do something super
conservative with water so I just kind
of left that I really don't have any
I don't lean any certain way politically
as far as water reclamation
commissioners but there were a few
issues on Chicago ballot specifically
that I had to look up on my phone when I
was there in the booth to have some more
knowledge on one of them we got to vote
on whether the revenue from the roads
and different things like that was that
like the safe roads one I think that was
that where whether that revenue from all
from all those sources could only be
spent on on those things
and so I looked I did a little research
on it and it seemed like a lot of
reasonable people say you should say no
so this so that money can be allocated
to different things in case of a crisis
I saw ads for it on TV and really they
spun it like as a that's a no-brainer
everybody wants good roads yeah I mean I
feel like the roads yeah it is good to
have good roads but I feel like they got
some extra money man oh that's holy
money well everybody has to deal with
potholes so they spun it like yeah do
you like potholes no you don't so you
should like the city of Chicago at this
point should have a very streamlined and
cost-efficient pothole fixing yeah
solution ace agree smooth that so I got
that got the vote and done and winnin
checked out my spot I went in checked
out the is almost ready to be up on
Airbnb some people were calling me a
slumlord
online I saw some people yeah man wait
you're not a landlord yeah he's kicking
east change he's buying buildings and
kicking people out of them oh it's not
the it's not the Mel is not the monotone
Hannibal that we used to love with the
pickle juice yeah yeah wouldn't people
are getting that money yeah
and so I was obviously looking I'm
constantly looking at properties online
and I go on this site loop net.com and
ask commercial properties and your
building came up yeah I wasn't searching
this zip code it just came up on him
when I was scrolling through your
building came up yeah homie called me
about it a couple months ago he was
letting me know that uh yeah pretty much
leases up August and yeah August 31st
your lease is up it says that on there
yeah it was weird to read that about
because they had all the information on
the list
yeah all the information he said it's a
it's a you know it's a retail property
and then there's a unit above with a
long-term tenant in there that leases up
August 31st 2017 you know it was
to read that about my my friend I think
she [ __ ] if I'm being honest about the
property itself I think it's overpriced
it's absolutely I mean the guy said it
to me straight up when he called me he's
like cuz I was like well what are you
looking to sell it for cuz I love this
apartment yeah I was just like maybe I
might look into it yeah and he's like
I'll tell you straight up it's gonna be
way above market price yeah cuz the
neighborhood's hot and he's like you're
not gonna want to do it he said but so
he think he's gonna get it easily I
think I think he's gonna you think he's
gonna get it I think I cuz I looked at
it and you said oh maybe you should buy
it no personal be a weird dynamic to buy
the place that you live in and also it
is over price ya know it's I think
there's a chance that it might even go
up they have a long-term lease
downstairs oh it's like I think that
they think they're locked in from it
they have something like a triple net
lease out there where that means if some
I can't explain it I guess is something
good if you own it yeah I wonder how
much they pay for rent uh he told me but
I it's something very reasonable yeah he
told me but I can't remember but I do
remember thinking like oh that's
definitely not gonna justify the price
at his building yeah thought it would be
funny a Tony got some good news and some
bad news
get out of here right now we gotta go on
tour my contract they can't yeah but he
said to me he was like he was like yeah
I might need you to move earlier and
he's like I'm sure there's a price that
we can agree upon to make that happen if
there needs to happen and I'm like yeah
sure whatever
I mean if it's like a month's rent I'm
gonna be like no because I want to stay
as long as I can but if he's like here's
five grand I'll be like peace nice it's
a hot neighborhood it's a hot
neighborhood so high neighborhood here
in Chicago two Cubs one mm-hmm
the Cubs won the World Series tell him
about that that Airbnb that you found
that was fronting like they were a
Wrigleyville
yeah it was I guess for the Cubs games I
was looking for a spot to stay I wasn't
I was when I was in the showers looking
for sponsors to kick it one night and it
was this place to sit all right bye
Wrigley in in Logan Square in Logan
Square if you don't know Chicago Logan
Square and Wrigley are not right next to
each other different kinds that even
easy to get to this is just totally
different but people were trying to
capitalize I wish I was in a city when
it happened I didn't want to be right in
the mix I don't know if I would have
wanted to be in Wrigleyville when the
Cubs won cuz I think I would have went
crazy but yeah it was dope to see and we
were in DC mmm just finished up our gig
while they came my show in DC I was
pretty I was pretty cool and Al Jackson
was with us he's from Cleveland it was
fun to just talk [ __ ] so yeah it was
just fun it's just fun to talk [ __ ] to
somebody about and I don't even care
about baseball that much and I'm a
bandwagon fan and that's probably what
made it hurt more cuz he's probably
thinking I never heard you talk about
the Cubs until last month and yet you
got them right I'm a straight-up
bandwagon fan riding the wave and so we
watched the game at a bar across the
street from the venue then the rain
delay happened then we went back to the
air B&B and they won and we just got to
talk trash to out and he was really sad
for that mom I don't know if he was
faking sadder he's real sick he might
have been I don't know uh I think I
think he's still riding the wave off of
uh the cavity he's gonna be okay
he was kind of it was a moment while I
looked at I mean took a picture of I
think of war I think he eats chilled out
you know a half hour later yeah no I got
it back together but yeah I just was it
that's crazy that parade five million
people is only three million people in
Chicago it would have been it would have
been nice to be in and being that energy
I just I just
get back now oh man
you know what uh I flew in today
it was nice smooth flight you know I
don't I always wonder when I had my
boarding pass to the TSA mm-hmm what
does that [ __ ] they scribble on
there I have always wondered what are
they scribble on there I don't know what
is that [ __ ] because it's never is not
consistent sometimes it's just some
indecipherable [ __ ] yeah sometimes their
initials in a number and they just
scribble some [ __ ] is just a show
because if you use mobile boarding pass
they can't just scribble on your phone
they can what did it what does that [ __ ]
that they're scribbling cuz I've never
gotten into the gate and then had the
American Airlines person say hey you
can't get on a plane you don't got no
random scribbly [ __ ] on your
boarding pass what all right see any TSA
agents that listen please email the
handsome rambling Gmail and tell us and
the world what that [ __ ] has you be
scribbling is I would I just really like
to know right genuine why you scribble
it on my [ __ ] who are you
yeah let me let me write on something
just stop you ain't right it's nothing
special you know I'm like I don't like
when I go to a to a borrow club you ever
have a guy look at your ID too long yeah
it's a it's a certain threshold yeah
it's a it's a reasonable I think it's
about a once they go past five seconds I
think that's that's it for me on the ID
is with I had a my date one two three
four five you got it beyond that what
the [ __ ] are you looking for you see you
see come on stop looking at I got into
it I got into it on the other side
coming back from Canada oh well I didn't
get into it
it was what the US Customs like in a cow
at the Calgary Airport it was the u.s.
customs lady at the air why don't I have
guns for
well they always have guns and it don't
seem like that's where the [ __ ] goes
down it lets need the hare know that and
so she uh she asked me what were you
doing in Canada I said I was doing a
show doing a comedy show and she said
what is your title and that kind of put
me in a weird spot and my title of it
was my show Hannibal bird like it's felt
like a weird thing to say so she she
asked me what are you doing here I was
doing a comedy show what's your title it
was my show and then she asked me some
something else and and then she asked me
where I was born and this is and I was a
little tired and I was already we are
already in dude you already crossed the
border this is no day they didn't have
it at some Airport they have it at the
Canadian Airport they have the u.s.
customs per people so you think those
people are do you think they live in
Canada or do you think there are
American citizens that live in Canada or
do you think they're Canadians that work
for the American the American border
border I think they're American citizens
that they live in work in Canada at the
airport conflict of interest
it seems seems weird did they have it
they I don't know I guess that makes a
smoother for you to do it there and you
just land in America and keep it moving
I don't know but something at some
places they just have it as some
Canadian cities you just go out and you
handle it no Canadian side yeah and
they'll even have a sign in part of
Airport welcome to America and [ __ ] off
we still in Canada shut up
and yes she asked me where I was born
why if she had my passport in her hand
and it says where I'm born on there and
so you know where were you born
it says it right there on the passport
do you know what my job is
to protect the border and then she says
meets a secondary screening secondary
what do they do there ladies do anything
it was just to do the dude knew me like
what's going on man like she was asked a
stupid question stop and uh yeah it was
just an extra couple minutes I don't
know I guess I just hate Authority um I
mean it was just it's on there it's on
the passport yeah so you think somebody
that went through the trouble of getting
a fake passport is gonna forget where
they're fake born it I think you see it
right there I'm coming back home yeah I
already had a lot of trouble coming in
on the other side you don't stop me from
from coming home I gotta live in Calgary
now cuz you got a bunch of dumbass
questions whatever welcome back I'm
excited to be back I'm very excited to
be back until these results results
still early it's only it's only 9 p.m.
Central Time just to give you a
real-time feel sometimes you don't know
where the podcast has happened unless
it's happening live like live streaming
but this podcast is usually put it is
9:00 p.m. Tuesday 8th Donald Trump is
Italy 137 former former host of The
Apprentice Donald Trump former Comedy
Central Roast so many things in the lead
with electoral votes right now and
actually as much as I don't like the
electoral college and how much it
diminishes the individual vote it takes
away power from the people hearing yeah
it does as much as I don't like the
electoral college and how much
diminishes and individuals vote I think
it might come in handy tonight because I
feel like it's gonna be tight and I
think Trump is gonna win the popular
vote and Hillary is gonna take the
electoral college really that is mine
that is what I think here at 9 p.m.
second time so we'll see how it plays
out seeking oh you didn't you are you
stupid
are you a last-minute spontaneous person
you didn't decide what you wanted to do
tonight we'll pull up SeatGeek
you can see what's going on in your town
that's what I do is just show you it
syncs up with your music library shows
you if your favorite artists plan and
you can just buy some tickets it shows
you the best deals that's what I do
I love see geek that's how I found out
how much people are scavenge for and see
how stupid they are when they're trying
to sell Hannibal Burres tickets for $400
in San Francisco that markets not that
strong for me or most comics $400 the
[ __ ] is wrong with you anyway see gig is
smooth it brings together all the ticket
insights under the seat geek interface
and you can just see it is awesome man
you see exactly where your seats are I
you see geek I do it all the time oh
yeah what are our plans oh yeah I know
exactly what we doing tonight
yeah I know exactly what we doing
tonight let me go to the bathroom real
quick now go to the bathroom take a [ __ ]
pull up see geek
boom we're gonna see Bruno Mars front
row thank you see geek to get your $20
rebate on tickets download the free CD
gap go to the Settings app and click add
a promo code
it's a promo code Rambla r am BL e are
seat geek will send you $20 after you've
made your first ticket purchase download
the free cg gap it's a promo code
rambling today yes
I want we gotta figure out I want to
figure out a twist with the podcast
something fun something different what
if I just did what if I just made
competing businesses for all of our
advertisers oh you like helix mattresses
we'll what about mine I got that - I
like that technology I'm into that - and
check out this food stuff I get and I
make clothes and I think I may do it
better yeah and then I can advertise my
own businesses on my own podcast and
charge myself nothing and I won't even
have to have specific stuff for the
reeds and the colds anything I could do
the ads I want to do it and I just
revolutionized the business that's that
yeah it's a it's a free market man yeah
free market have fun be loose DC was
fine I forgot in DC DC was fun DC we we
had two nights in DC one night at the
Howard Theater the other one at the
Lisner auditorium on George Washington
University campus the house says we
didn't have to travel today today it was
a good day to party and so you know we
have after parties a lot me and Tony DJ
and so wanted to have a twist on this
one so I mapped it out and saw that uh
the venue that our friend miles owns is
a Smith public trust is it was that
that's not after party venue it's about
15 minutes away from the Howard Theater
not that far but you know it's enough to
lose for some people to lose interest
and now when I go so I decided to try to
get a party bus so get a bus to take
people from the show to the party which
is an excellent idea
seems simple seems simple only problem
with this idea is that I came up with it
at 4:30
and my show I came with 4:30 p.m. and my
show is at 8 o'clock so now here's right
before you get into it here's the funny
thing is that
I literally left to do sound check as he
was on the horn trap our butts and then
yeah and then later on I was like I hear
yeah we got the bus we're good to go
I was impressed that you pulled it off
and says short notice you know what it
took a little bit I wasn't impressed
because some of them were this funny
people treat me like an [ __ ] for
calling and trying to stimulate their
business on a Tuesday again does that
many people getting buses on a Tuesday
get one of them drivers and pull that
[ __ ] out of a lot exactly
don't act like it's crazy and this one
woman was really rude on the phone and I
called her and then as I'm looking to
get into getting a party bus and she
just started into hard sales right away
are you ready to put down a deposit now
you just that you know what I don't even
know which I've got a Witcher yeah what
the what the what the inventory is she
just put out you put it ready to put
down a deposit and cut up and then we
started talking details I said we wanted
for about 9:15 and initially for what
what is it for what I said foot for
driving around a big group of people and
it said we don't have a bus and then
just hung up yeah
so other people just thought I was being
ridiculous for even trying to do
something that last minute or get it and
then eventually were able to pull it off
so shout out to whatever company that
was that uh helped us that way and help
us out you can just you know open can't
just think a place for being open and in
doing business oh thank you so much for
but they were professional and quote
that's a big ass bus it's a big bus it
wasn't exactly what I wanted but I mean
for two hours notice yeah it's pretty
good it was good but I wanted more of
the party bus type thing when you got
the music and the lights that's I put
that open space to kick it a couple of
those would have been coke and it was uh
it was fun man so you know got the bus
with the help of uh michael gracey from
squats creative
he was helping coordinate he caught it
the burger feat DJ burger feat Express
and we charge people five dollars a foot
which is a great deal a great deal five
dollars to get on the bus and then we
charge five dollars and that also gets
you entry into the after-party and and
lots of perks lots of like we gave shots
to everybody we I bought a hundred
dollars worth of scratch off ticket
scratch off lottery tickets yeah that
was funny and I don't think many of them
were winners it's a bad it's a bad
business was a great business but it's
bad for the people because nobody not
nobody unless somebody was just really
very subdued and chill about winning a
thousand dollars or they just didn't
want to admit wedding because they
didn't want to have to share their
winnings with you because you gave them
the ticket I would know I wouldn't know
why no but you know yeah or when they
win you don't think I don't think people
would be that reserved you think
somebody got one of G oh no yes so let's
say someone like twenty G's on a ticket
like that's like this in my pocket I
don't think I think somebody been so
psyched I think we would at least see
something on online on Twitter so I
don't think anybody I think a couple of
people won five dollars a couple of
people want a dollar yeah
but as far as a hundred dollars being
spent on a scratch-off tickets I think
came out - ninety dollars as a group
which is which is horrible horrible but
people have fun so have music on the bus
miles was a great bus conductor and he
was giving people you know those tour of
DC give it a lot of different insider it
was he was giving them the this is my
neighborhood tour life
see that's funny I got some great
Chinese food yeah this fog you could get
[ __ ] up over here two years ago that
was nice oh man yeah used to be lots of
crackers over there now it's all coffee
he was given a very specific tour it was
really the miles tour it was great I was
you know it could have been I think the
ride could have maybe went another 15 or
so that have been nice
yeah but yeah yeah you know it was a fun
different kind of
kind of energy especially you know I
like to do things last-minute kind of
keep it spontaneous so a party bus is
always great I mean I did want
Jojo hook one up for me once way back
like I had just gotten back from Taurus
she just hooked up a party bus and it
was just me and a bunch of friends and
there was like all this beer and a
cooler and we wrote it you know we're
medieval times is what suburb is that I
can't summer it's yeah I think it's I'm
not sure but it is one of them outskirts
but uh outskirts burbs but oh yeah we
took it took like 20 30 minutes to get
there but it is yeah it house the whole
time on the way and there's something
really fun about just being mobile and
drinking and then getting to the spine a
party in the music yeah you can get them
day all over Vegas and I um last time I
played Vegas we you own I get weird it
yeah not you got a party bus in Vegas
yeah remember that no you might not have
done the House of Blues gig in Vegas
I remember the limo the limo party yeah
oh yeah well yes we yeah you knows a few
of us and not just last man I just got a
party bus is maybe I want to say six
seven of us total and you know it was it
was just cool because you got you got
the liquor you get your bottle it
whatever the liquor store charges for it
you cook up your phone and play your
music and then these are some hobbies
all right you and your homies me my
homies and a couple yeah yeah what made
the DC one so special is that it was all
fans and we're just so psyched to just
be on the bus with you yeah I mean I was
I mean that's just a nice thing to do
for your fans
it felt just fine man there's more I
mean I can't kick it like that every
night yeah it's just cuz of my own but I
mean it's an experience that people
could talk about yeah at one time we
were all it bus would had but yeah it's
more it is more fun for me than it is
more fun for me to do that that it is
just go to some some random bar but I
just remember even Indies even in Vegas
of seven of us and we were kicking it
having
great time and then we will pull up to a
club at the Bellagio or whatever Caesars
and we go to the big nightclub Omni or
some [ __ ] and go in and then this is we
don't this is the bus is way more fun
the Busby tram five minutes in the club
and they get back on the bus I spent way
more time with a bus just cuz it was way
it just felt better taking you a crew
and then instead of sticking with your
crew just being amongst a thousand
strangers and his way louder and there's
confession occasionally and co2
sometimes yes sometimes the track like
when you do the parades in New Orleans
it's about the parade not the actual bar
ya know it's about great how you getting
to the bar that would make some fun you
know yeah do that New Orleans I don't I
think there's some people in New Orleans
that uh cuz I didn't you know I didn't
know that bit would do that when I when
I wanted it a bit about you know having
a parade in New Orleans the last minute
then you can you know get a band to
follow you around I think some people
man you've made it this suck and it's
douchebags doing it and then some people
yeah some people and then I'm I'm sure
some musicians that they could hey this
is this works out for us yeah but I did
it
it was so fun when I did it the first
time I was amazing I can't see I don't
know what I mean it would have to be a
I've done it well I did it would you
like yours was it this ii think the
second time and then i did it one time
after the plate the Civic you know i was
2014 that was when you brought yeah you
ended the show that way though yeah
awesome cuz you're like yeah alright
let's go outside knows a parade yeah
crazy some energy man
and try to uh and try to have some fun
into a transition into my my rap career
ain't got nothing else to joke about man
ain't got nothing else to joke about is
that mom hey I'm serious man now I ain't
get nothing else to joke oh god it's
just from now on it's just like faint
you know Lightfoot and so we get to that
that after-party in DC where the Cubs
win that night that goes on that night
the Cubs won tonight after AutoKey they
won that night so they won tonight yeah
oh yeah they won Game six that night
yeah oh man I think we got rid somebody
hit a home run right as the hook for
Wheaton boy yeah yes we for came on in
there yeah we and I got to make fun of
out and have a lively song on it was
perfect I love ya music when music just
randomly matches syncs up with life yeah
like that it is beautiful
I think this these coves victories
definitely wouldn't have been as fun
without al with us on the road it was it
was fun to just rub it in his face yeah
it was fun but you kept going you kept
on going out pretty much done I was done
after Tony you I had I was done after
the game was over all right we that's
fun we did that and then Tony yeah it's
all his clubs all day [ __ ] the Indians
man's got his braces oh hey man it's
done yeah you kept on even next day you
were going on yeah yeah it was a bit
much you know al Al's a good sport and
he was basically like you know what
that's all good I'm gonna give you 72
hours to get it out of your system
yeah my system you know I'm good that
was a great approach from a reasonable
man you know why was that al used to be
a teacher
that's how yeah let's go get out use use
access you know you got some stuff going
on
ten existed time just fine you and just
let you he was being understanding yeah
my man so you know as a lot of you
probably know i DJ under the name DJ
burger feet and my gig in DC was uh it
was a rough gig he was rough it is
probably and I've had some rough gigs as
you know sometimes it's going smoothly
and then sometimes it's just oh you
could just be off as is even you think
it's just playing songs or trying to but
I've had some weird
I've had some smoother nights I mean I'm
not a great blender I might have to take
some time out of my day or my my life to
learn how to blend and and you know do
it smoothly and be able to keep the
momentum going in a DJ set but this one
this was a rough one cuz you know Tony
spun for about 45 minutes or so and then
it was my turn to jump on the wheels and
in my first song transition I somehow I
don't know what I press on cerrado a
press whatever I press on a software the
song started playing backwards
I was outside the music is a lot I've
never pressed something of just it just
went backwards I was like how did you do
this you're like I don't know I don't
know what man
that was oh we got it back together
pretty good but it was just but then you
did it again later I didn't hear somehow
they
I just need to learn how to not do that
I'll be 20% better DJ if I learned how
not to play the music back I've never
seen that much you know your DJ gig is
going poorly when you play a song and
then P if people are invited to it much
I would say that at least it's not going
backwards you guys understand [ __ ] like
that music I played three songs
backwards yeah so there's a rough it's a
rough gig man I've had some ruffles
Oakland was a rough one I was high as
[ __ ] in Oakland and I hadn't hadn't DJed
high before and I just was overthinking
it is you think it's easier to DJ drunk
or high definitely drunk like hey man
when I like yeah when I get drunk that's
I spend my best set you're like straight
up like when I'm like blackout drunk
that's one of the best yeah because I
just get like I start dancing and you
get into it and I just start knocking
stuff over and like I get wild and like
people see that they feed off of that
you put it out in the universe that way
but yeah you have plate of stuff that
you want to hear that you're really dry
yeah so you connected when you're high
yeah you get too much into your head
when I was high and Oakland on it today
I don't know if they're gonna like this
Oh what is their Energy's like oh I
don't know
I was really second-guessing everything
and so it made for a very timid weird
ass set although they did vibe out when
I played that Kamiya how does it feel
but that's because it's a local artists
and they like but you know it's cool too
it's fun playing local stuff when you go
so certain that's if they like get it
because I remember we did a gig once
where it's like in tech we're somewhere
where we were oh we're in Houston I
believe it's at Houston or no no we were
in Memphis and I was playing a bunch of
like Tennessee stuff and Memphis [ __ ]
like yeah you know like rap tune
specific and specific to the town and
nobody knew what was going on well yeah
but the cuts that I picked we're like
three six yeah like you know 8-ball MJG
stuff like that and yeah just we're just
like lost I mean I don't know these
songs
really
Memphis duh I forget the name at a venue
but yeah yeah I remember doing that I
remember I was trying to do that for a
bunch of cities this is before I was
doing the video stuff and it just it was
weird because a lot of cities just
didn't know their own [ __ ] there'd be a
couple people on the power few people in
the crowd really yeah yeah for the most
part most people were just like this is
a bunch of rap music I've never heard so
I stopped doing that you gotta just
power through man no this video [ __ ] is
where it's at yeah
this is the universal everybody can get
down with it I like here I mean I get
excited here in Chicago [ __ ] anywhere
man you know you know how do you know
you've watched the Congo stuff's going
through a renaissance right now too so
like everybody likes Chicago [ __ ] right
now you know it's you you got you don't
even know have you tired of that song
I've been over playing it the Billy
Williams story
I'm not tired of it I'm just like oh it
was that song again yeah I probably play
is this art is Sabha from the west side
of Chicago I thought it was Kid Cudi
when you first played it sounds like it
really yeah it's not very kid cudi you
got a sword a dad fight it does have a
different vibe to it
mmm I don't know man I just like that
song a lot it gives me hyped was dry I
was driving from the airport listening
to it today yeah man and he got this
other song called Westside bound 3 see I
haven't I haven't listened to his solo
stuff but I did like him on angels yeah
it was real good on Westside bound you
don't know I'm from the west side of
Chicago and I'm from the West yes so
he's talking about Lupe from the west
side yeah dude a crucial conflict you
know that all of you know paid I'm
sitting well but he you sob I he's
talking about streets he's all my [ __ ]
there's a four blocks away from my
parents grave you start with division in
Austin and different specific side
streets just real like deep cut
West Side Chicago [ __ ] this is exciting
here you should see how angry Tony's
getting at this dog
be mad at that dog because it's ruining
his podcast people in Germany are
listening to this and his dog is [ __ ]
it up I'm gonna have to just put him in
the room aha but I feel like he might
whine more I mean just let it be in the
background whining a little bit I think
that get I mean maybe that just shows
humanity on our part is just that you
know life isn't everything you know life
isn't it's all perfect sound
maybe he's and he's pacing around like
he nervous because of this election or
maybe the dog is trying to you know be
on the podcast because it is one of the
top-ranked podcasts on iTunes yeah yeah
thanks thanks for listening it has been
it's fun is it it's uh it's fun having a
podcast man that's great I want to do
some different things with it is it's a
it's a good outlet it's a good outlet
talking about [ __ ] I was just back in
New York we were back in New York did
the Apollo Theater yeah that was that
was awesome Apollo Theater in Harlem
Chris Rock came through yes he came
through and so I asked him if he wanted
to go on you know no expectation he said
yes the way that went down too because
we were like right on the side stage by
hand was ready to go up I don't know
where this guy comes in through the
sides like it wasn't even noted I look
and I'm like oh [ __ ] and I think it was
like within like a two minute span and
then you were like you want to sometime
Klauss David abacus I wasn't sure you
know sometimes I would be not sure if a
cat wanna open for you you know what I'm
saying yeah and I would eventually have
that caliber yeah so I wanted to be I
mean I was but I also might as well as
it does it's almost it doesn't it
doesn't matter it's a crowd as comedians
want to do comedy you know what I'm
saying
and so as a PAC theatre mm-hmm and you
know we I've known him like seven years
now six seven years and we're right
around when I started on SNL and rock
he-man Tony introduced him
and it's just a crate it was just this
it's a different type of just energy
from the crowd that is pop this drop in
energy surprise guest energy and I've
gotten some nice pops from the crowd
when I when I've come to spots yeah and
it's been you know that feels it's a bit
obvious pop this [ __ ] when he roasts
it's different yeah it's just a
difference like a roar like oh it's on a
straight-up rocks it's like yeah like
this all this yeah it's just a different
it's crazy in any uh when and did uh did
a few minutes yeah I like that too
because he wasn't like it didn't feel
like he was trying out his bits it was
more like he was talking about the
election yeah what's going on like kind
of like it was almost like he took the
roles like public service announcement
yeah you know but was funny like yeah it
was it was a it was cool to see man yeah
and you know it really energized the
crowd definitely energized the crowd
even though my first instinct when he
was killing at first I was thinking what
if I'd done before peed myself through
it all I mean this is cool and
everything but this is uh but it wasn't
that type of said it was it not and he
didn't put that kind of a set on yeah he
wasn't we know he killed it and did his
thing but it wasn't the end of the way
yeah the wave kind of is that you know
you can ride the way yeah certain times
where I remember him coming through
knitting factory years back yeah and
killing it and and doing this day and
then somebody else went out and you know
he rocket but sometimes you you could
just ride the wave you know instead of
if you instead of it's not like okay I
can't follow that
do you really suck unless you really
suck of course but yeah just follow the
energy inches and have fun so I went out
there it was cool man a good time
I mean those at the end of the day those
people were there to see you yeah yeah
it's not like you go up there and be
like I can't follow this right yeah but
also I could feel that the energy when I
went up was definitely yeah hi yeah oh
you know what vibe just my first eye a
few jokes it was it was it was a
different
the crowd was in a different place and
they usually aren't people usually are
in a good spot and um
excited so it was it was a it was a dope
night and then finished up I quit before
you going yeah I when I first walked
into the Apollo I was like I can't man
I'm from but from watching it on TV I
always imagined the Apollo to just be
huge yeah very big it looks so big on TV
but like walking in I'm just like this
is like a small theater it's like it
looks like a normal size regular theater
you know did you get that feeling too
what like in person it doesn't feel as
big as on I guess that's like with all
theaters maybe right because a lot of
things just because in general with
television stuff to have a huge space
doesn't really lend itself to good shots
yeah you know what I mean yeah yeah also
having to feel a spot for television
yeah yeah generally places are smaller
than you think whether it's yeah you
know you go to Conan studio or Letterman
yeah like Letterman Show was shot I mean
it's no shots of it do you some shots
across but Letterman think that theater
doesn't it no see those late night shows
always look small to me I always look
small to me but the Apollo always look
huge for some reason yeah it's uh I mean
it does have those three tiers yeah yes
three tiers which is it the main level
and then is it three up or the to
infinity but it was a beautiful spot I
wish I got there early to check up but
it was you know the energy was crazy
Alicia Keys was playing the next night
so when I was there for soundcheck like
they had like two different unions
working at once oh really out it all
these lights and all those guys got this
huge board and there is
yeah he's doing a thing tomorrow and I'm
like yeah but we got a show tonight keys
you know take a hell yeah she take a
look and maybe a little priority at the
end of the day it's still a sold-out
show so all our shows a sold-out show
her new album just came out I heard it
was I heard it was it was good it must
be good cuz one of my buddies is really
into hip-hop you know I usually wouldn't
say this but that Alicia Keys is good
like I don't know yeah he just texted me
dudes like yo not a hard dude but mostly
uh mostly a hip-hop dude he's mostly
just hip-hop dude he like yo Alicia Keys
out zone so she killed it a chances
thing at the all yet a magnificent
coloring world yeah yeah how long did
you do like five minutes I did as short
as possible you still good though man
yeah I did I just try to get it and get
out yes so big of a I just wanted to
basically you know it's crazy to see you
up there oh yeah it was like a big-ass
[ __ ] catwalk and like yeah yeah Tom
afford it chances fest chance the rapper
had a festival in Chicago at US Cellular
Field I don't think as US Cellular Field
anymore it's uh no its Comiskey its
Comiskey but it US Cellular's is really
Comiskey
same two US Cellular what does isn't
that as horrible but that now is like
best low rates or some [ __ ] guaranteed
rates guaranteed rate soft filled sounds
terrible guaranteed rate I get that you
gotta I mean congratulations your
company being that successful and able
to usurp US Cellular up out of it but
guaranteed rate field is that the name
of the company yeah guarantee getting
some kind of like Lanka but but you know
if you concede great ironically its kind
of suitable because or not ironically
but coincidentally its kind of suitable
because the Sox are known to be like the
affordable team yeah versus like the
Cubs games are always overpriced what
yeah so it's like you got that
guaranteed rate guarantee you know
didn't you a cellular have
flat billing like flat rates as far as
like the foam yeah bill there's another
concurrent Eid rate
I guess sums that bad yeah it's a bad
name it's um it's a sound okay they
don't is some of them that don't sound
like a company even though they are a
company yeah like Wrigley Wrigley Field
is a common staple center sounds regular
Staples Center yeah targets it stuff
like that but guaranteed rate field it's
a rough one but such as life I guess
business have been in business have been
as it business it business I can see you
I see you hey oh stop did see you there
blue apron ad time blue apron can you
cook are you stupid
are you smart doesn't matter blue aprons
for stupid and smart people that can't
put together ingredients blue apron puts
together the ingredients and none of
them are poison
they're very against poisoning their
customers cuz that would be a horrible
business model blue apron calm since pre
meals
what pre meals no they send meals with
the ingredients already there measure it
out for your stupid ass so you ain't got
to do nothing so you ain't got a poor
bunch of salt on it like a dummy you
don't have to put some any B's in there
and have your stomach all bent out like
a goofy blue apron does it and they do
it with that beef in that chicken that
has not been tortured that chilled beef
and chicken cuz you don't want that
angry chicken in you because they're you
taking that angry energy and now you
angry and then you bout to go attack
your family since because you didn't get
some chill chicken what does it mean in
life well I'll tell you what the reading
of blue apron is it's having nice chill
meals portioned feel good you eat it and
you feel light and you can do a jog or
you might just you know you eat this and
you feel like you can kind of
seats a class or something teach people
how to sing you know what type of meals
they got in November pan-seared chicken
with roasted fowl vegetables and butter
caper sauce spiced and lotus root and
purple carrots stir-fry sweet potato
noodles lemongrass relish the plant with
Romanesco Romanesco and coconut rice
coconut rice coconut rice check out this
week's menu and get your first three
minutes free with free shipping by going
a blue apron comm slash Rambler you will
love how good it feels and tastes to
create incredible home-cooked meals with
blue apron so don't wait that's blue
apron dot-coms last rambling blue apron
a bro
so go down to Caroline's Eric Andre has
a gig pop up on Eric Andre's show do it
do a set he's a loser his fans are
pretty amped that you got a crazy
ovation it was a user it was a good it
was a good energy from the crowd yeah
the fans at that show were pretty
intense a very lot of people filming so
I didn't really want to try that most
and then a lot of people just yelling
stuff yeah I don't really nail down I
don't really get that I don't get what
to do when somebody hits nailed down
okay that's you know it's funny cuz your
fan base was very segregated like you
got your broad city fan base
you got your Eric Andre's fan base and
then you got your straight-up stand-up
fan base I think there's a lot of
overlap with Bryce City and Eric Andre
yeah I think initially they were I think
initially de bras City when Bryce City
was fun and his fan base and Eric
Andre's fan thing now it has been to
kind of merge I think there's been some
overlap but your Eric Andre fan base is
crazy they look crazy this is weird cuz
they'll yell you know the show was fun
to do but they'll yell like bits at me
from the show but I didn't I didn't
write that stuff so I'm not super yea
connected to it I think it's good if
buddy likes nailed down like I'm not
like a kid and also I don't wanna I
don't know what the hell bow yeah I
don't know what to do with that if you
yell it at my show when I'm performing
stand-up totally unrelated in front of
2,000 people would you just yell out
snail down and it was like Eric Andre's
like comedy like he write stuff like or
whoever writes stuff like that is
perfect for that kind of like just to be
yelling out I'm the deliverer feeds a
ball like people just want to scream
[ __ ] like that so like when you play in
front of his audience like that's the
kind of personality that you're bringing
you know there are
no no don't think so that's what
Chappell hated he hated with my father's
who he was doing stand-up either Rick
James [ __ ] it's just a separate yeah
you connect with those you like those
catchphrases they're fun to say but this
net is not a rap show he's not using
that hook there's not the hooks to my
[ __ ] this isn't that so you throwing off
somebody when you just yell it out a
catchphrase you can yell out
catchphrases as much as you want at the
bar with your friend but if you yelling
that at a show you throwing out yeah
like in the middle of a standard Standa
maybe right before somebody start or
something is go to yell but you know
pick you up people be yelling out I have
some stories so I have an eight-minute
story and somebody just in the middle of
a story Hannibal huh yeah why would you
Hannibal yeah I'm uh yeah I was in the
middle of the middle of a long story
about my uncle dying what's up you wanna
what was it what was that was that at
the Apollo with the douchebag up front
with the that was by himself
yeah that way he was laughing at weird
places he was texting I got it was so
annoying that it was text in a big
portion of the show recording the whole
time he was recording the whole time
security wasn't that on the job also had
friends that was sitting next to him it
they could have done a little something
yeah I could not stop here was a guy I
don't know if he was Australian a son
because he was bonded a little bit when
I talked about Australia's up front and
then uh you know attacked he was by
himself so I don't know if he was just
you know rolling solo bought one ticket
on StubHub or some [ __ ] and just it was
weird to see a person bite himself but
the seat next to him was empty front row
maybe there was a couple next to him and
then a couple next yeah to the empty
seat so I think he got stood up
huh or maybe somebody got sicker I don't
know but ya know I was watching him the
whole time and he was annoying the [ __ ]
out of me because yeah he was on his
phone [ __ ] around it was one of those
guys like where you said the funny [ __ ]
and people were laughing completely just
dead yeah not no response but then
he's looking at his phone and then he
would randomly just look up and be like
hahaha
at parts that weren't even like he just
like wasn't there like he did not
present at all during the show yeah that
may I mean he had like no reason to be
there it was strange to me yeah and then
he got up and left
I got up last 20 minutes in the show
yeah what were you doing there make me
wonder about the you know I've done a
bunch of shows with Chappelle they use
that the yonder the yonder yonder is
where they have these sleeves that
people put on just right we did that
Napa Valley yeah we did it no but we
tried it in Napa yeah and and so it is
wet he had his sleeves and they put that
phones and there they keep their phones
with them and and yeah so the pouch is
like a lock the pouch is locked then
people got their phones with them and
you can't you you can't access your
phone it's you step into the lobby on
your way out
yeah and so you know I've done a bunch
of shows was available to past few years
and he's recently started doing that and
the ones I've done with them lately
the crowd is just so just focused
yeah just Tintin as it is slightly it's
a slightly different energy I would say
if I could quantify it I would I would
say the audience is maybe 15% better
yeah so why don't why don't you utilize
that is it cost more than what like it
it does cost more money how much does
something like that cost it depends on
the venue negotiation or whatever but I
think I think I will but you know here's
the thing here's what is it a
significant cost is that worth the cost
you think it's uh I think it ranges
anywhere like a couple dollars a head it
could be anywhere from some dialects of
four dollars per head which is a lot you
know in some place you know it's you
know Apollo Theater it might have cost
you whatever the people don't deal Delta
Chi oh she ate so yeah three thousand
three thousand four thousand dollars no
I mean but it is is it is distracting
just when somebody's filming me you know
it's just it sucks it throws me it
throws me off
two rows me off on my scooter somebody's
just right up front by popping it over
my kit somebody's it's right there yeah
I can't really you can't get loose yeah
I can't do it get loose and do it the
way I want to you know when I used them
yonder
once I was like past them how much
there's no cause and then they oh well
you know you're gonna be in Napa will
you could use the service for free oh
nice that's it cool and then we use it
was smooth he was you know Napa might
have even been the right crowd to test
it on you know what I mean as far as its
effectiveness with it was it worked but
that Napa Valley crowd might not have
been crazy you know filming stuff who
knows whatever but then that gig was
Saturday and then Monday you know all
these press releases I would Hannibal
burn you justice Emily wait I didn't
know y'all were doing this yesterday
blast didn't they used I remember it
goes yeah like I was you would have
thought I had equity in the company yeah
as many articles and I was like you know
the service was cool but damn and I know
you was gonna kind of pimp me out like
that I mean do you agree with the
service or do you like say you are the
other side of it you went to go see like
knowing that you're not gonna use your
phone or whatever but you probably use
before I mean it's but I wouldn't do it
like blatantly and or but so like if you
went like I was like like I was like I
would like to be at some point like
checking it like just add up straight
yeah muscle memory nurse I would
definitely I would have if they were it
was somebody they like it sucks ya know
if the artist wanted to do it and I was
hard yeah you burn with it because I've
also I've seen what I've seen the vibe
yeah and I see why artists do it
especially somebody except L you know
there's working on new material that
compromises that if somebody filmed I've
seen one [ __ ] put up fool Chappelle
sets on YouTube Dave Chappelle out there
and she's like 50 minutes long
on YouTube
come on but uh so it helps and it I
remember you remember you remember the
hip-hop group all natural from Chicago
yeah
so I remember there's a you know empty
bottle they're playing at the empty
bottle once and you know the mother he's
Muslim capital D the lead guy and he had
a stipulation if he played there
they couldn't serve alcohol oh wow
straight up and this one you can still
smoke in the bar said no smoking no
alcohol and they straight-up did that
for him was all natural they were pretty
big back then they were like one of the
biggest underground hip-hop groups in
Chicago at the time that running it but
that was like unheard of for like a bar
to just be like there's no liquor here
so me and my guys just snuck in a bottle
and got [ __ ] up that's free watch the
show there's no liquor at all no liquor
at all no liquor at all they were
serving [ __ ] soda and water bro like
nobody was drinking liquor that's a
strong move it's a very strong move and
like I remember like pickle was with me
and he asked the door guy who's like hey
Matt he's like is this for real and the
guys like yeah
we really respect all natural hey hey
that's but that's crazy that anybody
would have that kind of power to just
any artist had that power to be like no
alcohol and that's no alcohol I mean
that's obviously under ain't [ __ ]
compared to that well yonder is it's not
even comparing cuz yonder is just
bringing in someone asking people to put
something away and they still keep it
versus asking a venue to not make money
yet so yeah well one of the main revenue
streams but I wonder if you know in his
deal did he have to give away a bigger
percentage of the door well if they just
you know sent the gig sometimes venues
they might I mean empty bottles a
cool-ass van yeah they're like
historical for putting on some really
doves right so they took the hell
sometimes places you know that's what I
found as you build relationships yeah
with places yeah you know you started
looking back oh there was a lot of money
on the table
y'all just didn't [ __ ] with me like that
yeah I know it's places that you I used
to be able to get you
oh yeah you doing it we doing a 50/50
split or 60/40 and now here's some spot
that same spot I'll come through and
it's just straight mm-hmm a hundred
percent
here's the money here's everything that
came in oh [ __ ] I should have asked
without a while ago yeah man
well I my energy is better in Chicago
now when I get into New York I turn it
to this something that there I think I
basically live here now again when I'm
in New York I turn it to this [ __ ]
fake like tragic artist self-destructive
type of [ __ ] way I'm just upset and
over do you know is this something about
it now when I go back I have a good time
but then the nights can get too long and
it's a bit much but Oh something when I
got back here I got back energized man I
have fun doing the Apollo of doing the
shows with Eric and and all of that and
I went to Knitting Factory Sunday but it
was just I just felt you know weird ass
it's so weird a smooth the city puts me
in now every time I every time I get
there it just feels like a flash
everything is just like never enough
time to catch up on anything
yeah it's up so I mean it was you know
it's weird having that apartment there
I'm speaking of which I get that [ __ ]
cleaned up that's funny some people
would write me about the Edinburgh
documentary yeah
clean your place clean your place like
that was four years ago wasn't it it's
not how it looks anymore you still have
that same place though also quick note
if you ever watched high maintenance
that place is in high maintenance also
and then for the HBO episode of high
maintenance they recreated that [ __ ]
with the mess and everything and they
had out crinkled stuff really yeah
they've recreated they made a day of my
old place they made a set out of I
thought that was actually your place in
the HBO 100 the web series one the way
wait you're on I didn't see that yeah
you're on the HBO one yeah I'm gonna
vo one oh I just saw the webseries yeah
on the web series one from a few years
ago where I remember that yeah and then
I'm gonna do a quick cameo on HBO and
they made a shitty place recreated it
cuz they have money now yeah the show
was doing well they like we don't need
to shoot in your apartment but the first
one wasn't make your apartment the first
I was gonna say they did a great job
which when they shot I had so much cuz I
hadn't had that many people over my
place at once at that one I think at
most I had one or two people over my
place yeah at that time
yeah and it was this crew it was a small
crew but it was still a there's six
people in my place and I only know one
of them sort of but yeah that show it
was that's a dope show man I'm it's
crazy seeing how they've kind of
developed and progressed and done it
their way and now it's on HBO yeah it
was a web because I was already idea
because it's already thought in eight
they kind of took it slow and I think
they probably had other opportunities
early on because right away when I I
don't know when I did at the time might
have been 2012 yeah it's when I saw the
other episode why isn't this on TV
already but it's a good timing it's a
great idea it's a great show the cast is
good yeah yeah Danone is really good
yeah it was uh yeah it's time for
questions questions questions questions
questions questions questions questions
questions questions questions alright so
he says uh this is from if you use this
please don't use my full name just use
my initial P so this is from P mm-hmm P
big Hannibal yeah my wife is from
another country and we've been kept
apart due to visa issues okay recently
we found an excellent lawyer this woman
is very sharp and knows everything about
immigration huh if anyone can fix our
problem it is her alright so the three
of us had a Skype conference one morning
it was a good meeting meeting and we all
were feeling pretty positive I start
doing it we can do that sometimes you
have a meeting
oh yeah it's a good meetings meetings
awesome something when you first started
you know trying to build as a stand-up
your agent will send you to LA you go on
a bunch of general meetings yeah
just general just general meetings and
you'll go to LA you get a rental car and
you just go to a bunch it's true it is
casting people somebody that works at
show Entourage you just go isn't that
entourage it's not like entourage
because they don't these [ __ ]
don't know who you are
oh at all no they suck it'll suck is
just mic so what's your I guess is a lot
of times cuz I end up working with out
of the general mean a couple people out
of lots and lots of general means I
ended up you know working with in other
capacities years down the line but the
vibe of Mars is like so what sure you
just sit down yeah what's your story
what are you just general just meeting
generally no sometimes there's a good
one and you feel it sometimes I mean you
could talk and vibe with somebody but at
this you that picture nothing like I
didn't I'm just meeting I didn't have
anything I don't even really want to act
that much I was like I'll do stand-up I
like doing stand-up yeah this is what
we're up to and they just we're doing
this so we got these projects and
development but I don't having a script
to pitch I didn't have anything they
weren't casting at the moment yeah it
was just a general meeting general
meeting just a general asked me let's
just have a conversation that's one we
started asking girls I don't owe you on
a general meeting that's better than
coffee let's do a general meeting have a
general mean man yeah it should be on
your tinder profile I'm into general
meetings and yeah sunny ways it was a
good meeting feeling pretty positive so
I started doing a sexy little dance for
my wife as a joke after a few minutes
though we stop joking and start getting
serious outcome the sex toys vibrators I
can't recommend them strongly enough she
has to see my [ __ ] and it's on so then
we finish out come the clean up stuff
and then we realize we left our attorney
in on the call now she didn't say
anything and she might have been gone
it might have been hung up but I don't
know we could have been given her whole
loft from a free show for a half an hour
I should note that although I love my
wife deeply if we were on red tubers
redtube or something most people would
skip the video in the first five seconds
okay self-aware anyway I don't know if
she saw but I do know she cashed my
retainer check should I fire her and
look for a new lawyer uh I mean you know
you think this is real is probably real
could he said I mean it's very detailed
he said don't say my full name yeah so
yeah maybe that's him tryna trying to be
funny but I mean either way it is a real
situation so let's think about it as
real is it a real situation could be a
real situation that sounds specific it's
not immigration lawyer and all of that
yeah it sounds very detailed just to
tell a jagoff jokes oh yeah and I mean
if you took that much time here right in
the jagoff joke that's that long yeah
and let's entertain the idea no I think
you should I mean you talk with her
again try to gauge her vibe this is what
I suggest you set up another Skype
meeting under the guise of asking some
questions about something else about
something else pertaining the case and
then you kinda can fill out you'd be
able to like I think if you you seem
like a smart person you you'll be able
to read whether she saw you jacking off
on video or not she and let me she's
lawyer but people I don't know lawyers
are good at lying not good at but you
think she's gonna play it off and you
don't think I really just shift a little
bit but business is business like you
focus on your business and you write so
to check so she's no matter what right
so this is like and also you have you
have lawyer-client privilege yeah
so she's not gone she can't do that she
said me say what so don't worry about
what is the thing they would kick her
off they will kick her out of the bar
she'd be cut off at the bar cut off
but she be cut off at me on Saturday cut
her off at the bar she talked about you
jacking off because of a client lawyer
privilege out there so be chill right
good luck with that you and her and I
hope y'all come together and I'll be
able to put your parts together in
person instead of via Skype
anyways thanks P for your for your
question he oh and please don't forget
to write in to the handsome Rambler for
your questions we might answer oh yeah
you might answer your questions alright
you guys
god this is fun thanks for listening
thanks to Tony trip your wolf Flying
Lotus for the music share subscribe
listen all that stuff got a good time I
need a good sign on phrase whatever sign
up cut it off stop it now
thank you against the skin kind of skin
kind of skin skin condoms yeah smooth it
feels like nothing zone when you're
trying to go to bring ozone skin condoms
was popping skin condoms I'm not
stopping ready to try and head over to
buy condoms dot online so how about that
domain that online sounds like that's
from the 90s it's cause free shipping
free shipping on all lubricants and
condoms with cold Rambler Rambler buy
condoms dot online just buy a bunch and
get them sent straight to your place and
you don't have to look at the person at
Walgreens in the face even though they
don't care but you care and you thinking
about it too much and you're not living
your best smooth as life skin condoms
Rambler buy condoms that online buy hey
guys it's Franklin Leonard and we are
back with another amazing season of the
blacklist table reads we have so many
near movies for you this season and some
fantastic talent at the helm there is
Paul Scheer starring an insane action
comedy so get in chuckling it's your
last dance a dark new take on the story
of Frankenstein with the incredible
Joanne Froggatt
it was the intoxication of your words
that's kept me so tied to you Mary and I
used to Tyler in AI apocalyptic sci-fi
my name is Maggie mine is the story of
greatness plus interviews with our Leeds
writers and much much more
so listen in subscribe to the blacklist
table reads right here under way this
has been an ear wolf production
executive produced by Scott Aukerman and
Chris panic for more information and
content visit Earwolf dot-com
you